vous prenez le métro le matin par
exemple vous voyez des femmes avec des
gosses en émettront on est absolument
bousculer ciré elles sont obligées
dominé leurs gosses dans une crèche par
exemple c'est absolument scandaleux
qu'on fasse voyager les gens dans des
conditions pareilles
fonction du candidat ils sont tous des
travailleurs ouvriers techniciens
envoyés chi minh et du quotidiennement
dans leur entreprise qui sont des
militants syndicaux qui participent aux
luttes de la classe ouvrière
travailleuses travailleurs
c'est à vous que je m'adresse
particulièrement ce soir eh bien oui je
suis une femme et j'ose me présenter
comme candidate à la présidence de cette
république d'homme c'est légal et
pourtant cela choque cela paraît étrange
même aux hommes de gauche et cela doit
l'être puisque je suis la seule petite
fille modèle au jo du lot
je vivais dans un quartier ouvrier avec
pleins pleins d'enfants avec qui ont
joué
dans le jardinet qu'entouraient le petit
immeuble que j'habitais et je voulais
j'ai aimé les jeux mais je crois que
déjà j'avais un certain goût pour la
lecture c'est vrai aussi en tout cas je
ne regrette pas de m'être présenté
bien au contraire ce que j'ai dit dans
cette campagne a été au moins 10 par
quelqu'un et si les travailleurs ne sont
que s'en souvenir dans les mois qui
viennent je dis c'est déjà important
[Musique]
pour nous
la
saxe
[Musique]
bon on a compris que vous aussi vous la
voulez qui fait par
arlette dans le prénom était plus connu
que son parti vous êtes déjà demandé
nathalie arthaud pourquoi l épave ou en
tout cas vous un peu moins non jamais
jamais parce que la réponse est très
simple elle est très simple
effectivement la première femme à se
présenter en 74 ça a été un coup de
tonnerre moi je crois voilà et en plus
elle était la première donc à se
présenter à la présidentielle mais elle
venait de conduire une grande grève dans
le secteur bancaire et j'étais aussi
fait connaître à partir à partir de ce
moment là donc c'est toute une période
d'une période de combat sur sur tous les
plans à la fois des combats de
travailleurs des combats aussi féministe
donc cesser toute cette période là cette
lutte aussi contre la guerre d'algérie
parce que c'est aussi ça l'histoire
d'arles est elle s'est engagée à ce
moment là donc donc oui c'est une
période de politisation intense où les
femmes sont soit sont à l'avant et je
crois qu arlette elle elle représente ça
donc moi j'arrive après j'arrive après
avec les scores que
que vous n'avez pas atteint les scores
d'arlette laguiller elle dépasser 5% à
la présidentielle en 95 et 2002 oui mais
vous voyez elle s'est présentée en 74
les premières fois et la faute lui
fallut attendre 95 pour payer 5 % et en
fait c'est aussi 95 je pense une période
où finalement il y avait déjà une petite
remontée
d'un esprit contestataire dans le monde
du travail d'ailleurs ça ensuite il ya
eu les grandes grèves de 95 contre le
plan juppé enfin ça a été à un moment
important où il ya eu des millions de
salariés qui se sont manifestés qui ont
fait grève un vrai bras de fer et j'ai
l'impression que cette élection de 95
était finalement
annoncé cet cette remontée de conscience
ouvrière finalement
[Musique]